YES, EVEN THE JEWISH HOLIDAYS.
MY FAVORITE VIDEO ON THE
INTERNET RIGHT NOW IS OF QADDAFI
GETTING CAPTURED BY THE LIBYAN
REBELS.
OOH, THAT'S A LOT OF BLOOD
AROUND THE COLLAR.
YOU'RE PROBABLY GOING TO NEED
TWO TIDE STICKS TO GET THAT OUT.
THAT'S MORE THAN I THOUGHT WE
WERE GONNA GET TO SHOW.
BUT WHAT REALLY MAKES IT SPECIAL
IS THE PART
WHERE ONE OF 'EM TAKES OUT A
UTILITY KNIFE AND REPEATEDLY
JAMS IT UP QADDAFI'S ASS.
IF THEY CAN DO THAT TO A WORLD
LEADER, I MIGHT AS WELL DO IT TO
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK ON MY SHOW,
IN A NEW SEGMENT CALLED
QADDAFI'D.
EVERYBODY IN THE WRITER'S ROOM.
G
GADDAFI.
>> GADDAFI.
>> I JUST GOT GADDAFIED.
GADDAFI.
AH, ONE OF THOSE FELT SO RIGHT.
A BIG THANKS TO QADAFFI FOR
DYING SO WE COULD DO THAT BIT.